I really truly feel sorry for any young
people who fall for this this is the
problem too like a lot of people who
hate Andrew Tate they'll just see the
headline
I'm obviously a Muslim I'm Islamic what
most people don't understand about a lot
of the Islamic world is that a lot of
these things are outlawed right so
somebody sent me this clip of people to
Pride March shouting out uh we're here
we're queer and we're coming for your
children
they're telling the truth I even see
both sides of politics they're saying
why is Tucker Carlson interviewing a
human trafficker this is America's most
famous Admiral
he looks back he goes how you know about
Haram and then are you cautious about
your diet
um I'm not as cautious about my diet as
I should be I'm Christians are starting
to realize especially conservative
Christians that Islam are a lot of
people Envy the fact that reading the
book get wet
can we sir I'm sorry I is there was it
something I said I don't think he's a
human trafficker I think he's probably
done what would be considered Haram
[Applause]
and his final message
be upon him this is our religion Islam
Islam this is the beach
show
assalamualaikum greetings of Peace
everybody my next guess is an
independent news analyst he brings a
different and unique perspective to news
reporting he's back here on the dean
show
you guys know him has
anomaly thank you appreciate you thanks
for having me anomaly my man how you
doing brother how's how you been life is
good I was glad when you guys hit me up
it's funny I was just thinking about you
guys and that we should do another
interview and then I saw the email
literally in the same week or two so
great timing this was Destiny you see
you were thinking they were thinking how
and God made it happen huh
amen amen how's everything with you how
you been since the last time we got
together
everything's good just been trying to
work trying to have a little fun and uh
take care of the fam so life is good so
bring us up to speed you've been talking
about a lot of different things you
bring a unique and
unique perspective to news reporting can
you go ahead and bring us up uh we got a
few things here to talk about GMO
mosquitoes the Lockheed Martin Target uh
almost going under and the lab grown
meat uh Andrew Tate Being Framed uh you
reported on that there's a lot to talk
about where do you want to start
yeah I mean either one of those I guess
what I would say is I'm noticing in
politics because that's the field that I
dabble in that I thought a lot of people
were doing journalism citizen journalism
but now you have a lot of partisan
people right A lot of people that
I think they made a name and made a
Brand's questioning narratives telling
the truth now I feel like a lot of
people this year that's what I'm seeing
there's a lot of selling out and there's
not a lot of honesty so I always try to
no matter what the topic is politician I
try to be as honest as possible and as
Fair because I I don't want to be
compromised by a you know a politician
because then I can't do my job so we
could start maybe the mosquito thing is
definitely an interesting story if you
want to start with that yeah GMO
mosquitoes let's start with that
so a couple years ago they released
genetically modified mosquitoes in
Florida and in Texas and the reasoning
by the company was backed by Bill Gates
I think their name is oxteca like oax
e-t-ca or something oxyteca and their
plan was basically to kill mosquitoes
and lower the population by sending out
I think it was male mosquitoes that
can't have kids so just tricking
mosquitoes into mating with fake
mosquitoes to kill mosquitoes that's
what they said they released them into
the public and I'm not saying this is
the correlation they've done fact checks
of course on this and I I won't say
things that I can't prove I like to be
honest but malaria has popped up in
Texas and Florida for the first time in
a long time and those are the two states
that they released them in I'm not
saying it came from that but I do find
it interesting and just I don't know who
voted for this stuff this is the type of
stuff when people fight over Trump and
Biden and DeSantis and Biden the or
DeSantis and Trump these are the things
that they're doing and I don't think any
politician has the power to stop Omar
cares so that's why it's important for
citizens to pay attention and if they
don't want that voice your opinion about
it it's just one of the things that in a
free Society going by the Constitution
we have freedom of speech but then you
have also a lot of these social media
platforms where you can get canceled you
can get in some trouble talking about
certain things uh that happened to me
also when when the whole uh thing was
going down and people were locked in
their houses and we were talking about
certain things and certain videos were
removed is this some of the you let me
know which things we could talk about
which things we can't yeah I think
pretty much anything goes as long as
you're trying to be somewhat accurate
but you're right now I got videos taken
down during that and the funny thing is
once they get what they want now you
could talk about it right now now it's
okay oh now you can talk about it huh
right I remember when when the things
were going on if you question Matt asks
at all even if you did it in the most
well are we we're okay to talk about the
mass now I think you are because it's
all gone but I still try to be careful
as far as what I say but even if you're
careful they they they're selective and
unresponsive if they censor you
uh inaccurately they don't care you know
it's kind of like a dictator where
there's nowhere to talk to there's no
court to go to they say this you say
this and they win because they own
YouTube so let's uh let's get into the
next thing that kind of goes into that
and it gets your reaction because you
you also spoke about this community do
you take care of your immune system in
other ways do you take probiotics are
you cautious about your diet
um I'm not as cautious about my diet as
I should be I'm a junk food-aholic uh
actually well that seems like a terrible
thing for you it is a terrible thing for
my health and something my wife is
working on it but that seems ridiculous
for someone who works with health yeah
yeah
sometimes man I just don't get it right
how often what how often how often do I
steal a bag of chips or something like
that garbage yeah that does seem
ridiculous for anybody who's really
wanting to be more conscious of their
health the first thing you really got to
get down to is your nutrition this is
very important and it seems like when
Joe Rogan was asking him about his uh
nutrition lifestyle it was upside down
and this is one of the key figures for
health huh when they locked us down the
first Common Sense thing I thought was
if they could mandate a lockdown they
could mandate an exercise for the whole
country to exercise together and if
they're not doing that but they're
taking away sports and gyms and athletic
facilities then how much can they really
care about our health and you see that
with big Pharma everything comes back to
pills or vaccines pills or vaccines and
on an equation if there was a health
chart you know medicine would be one
part of that right taking care of
yourself with supplements or medicine or
whatever you think is medicine whether
it's food but then they act like the
rest of of the pie chart doesn't even
exist so someone like that get exposed
and they says do you take care of
yourself and he's like no and Joe's like
how your whole that's your whole thing
and he's like well yeah well because
he's just basically a big Pharma
salesman in my opinion and that's that's
an issue that both parties seem to not
care about and I feel like a lot of
politics is like WWE theater to get
people fighting when sometimes the top
of the pyramid is is controlling both
parties the lobbyists and certain
industries so yeah that was a great clip
to really expose the experts in health
they don't even take care of themselves
yeah what's this lockhead Lockheed
Martin you spoke about this
and the rainbow colored alphabet
movement that kind of got they got
behind and then but this is this is a an
industry that is making weapons or what
is it right yeah Lockheed Martin is a
weapons manufacturer and they're one of
the big I would say War lobbyists that
Lobby both parties and I think it's in
their interest to have wars and two make
new weapons because that's what they do
they put a rainbow flag and did some
sort of I guess Pride March or something
you know they they sponsored their own
rally and they had all the LGBT
activists in the street with them and
it's just funny because years ago it
used to be the left wing that was
against war and against Raytheon and
Lockheed Martin and all these weapons
contractors and lobbyists but all you
have to do is put a rainbow flag over it
and I guess if it's gay left Wingers
they don't do activism anymore are these
the same is this the same company that
was in places like Iraq and Afghanistan
and
do you know anything about that was that
probably I think Lockheed Martin and
Raytheon when it comes to all the U.S
weapons that they're using and funding
others with whether it be Rebel groups
or you know their allies I'm pretty sure
it's them you know if we're at War I'm
sure Lockheed Martin is a part of it
yeah have you have you started training
some martial arts so Jiu Jitsu or
anything you've been hanging around with
some of the USC Fighters yeah I've been
uh I hit the punching bag but I haven't
officially trained Jujitsu or anything I
do kind of want to take at least boxing
lessons and uh I want to get in like a
YouTube celebrity boxing match well you
do yeah try to punch somebody in the
face yeah legally
yeah so you interviewed uh a UFC fighter
not too long ago and you guys are
talking about it's a big thing right now
is the sexualization of the children can
you talk about that
yeah Holly Holm mentioned it after a
fight she won and she said I don't think
they should be sexualizing the children
and it caused huge controversy because
they they called it right wing and you
must be this and she said hey I'm just
talking about sexualization of children
in general I think it's going too far
and uh you know they're using the lgbtq
which is like a shield right because
then if you push back against it they
say you hate gay people or you're you're
being a bigot but they're starting to do
it lower and lower to younger and
younger kids and you know a kid thinks
that he's a truck driver because you
tell them about truck drivers or he
wants to be an astronaut or a
firefighter at a certain age you only
know what you're taught and you don't
really know who you are so they're using
the lgbtq plus thing to get into the
schools to push it on very young kids
who they don't even know their sexuality
I mean you know I saw I think her name
is Charlize Theron she's some celebrity
she adopted black kids from Africa and
they're like two three four five like
super young and she's transgendered them
and they're like oh they're they're
women now and they were boys and I'm
like you know this is pretty sick these
these kids barely know who they are and
their parents are you know trying to
change their sexual orientation it's
it's like gotten to such crazy Heights
they're not waiting until you're 18 uh
even it's like there's no age that isn't
too young for them how is that even
possible I was watching a clip of a
father he was talking to his son and he
was talking about what Mom gets him to
do and his mom is dressing up as a girl
putting makeup on them and she's kind of
like pushing what she'd like okay she
didn't get a daughter now she's like oh
it's unfair so now I'm gonna start to
make my son you know play the role of a
woman and she's programming him these
things take uh
take a they have a strong impact on the
children and then you end up messing
them up as they get older so we're
seeing a lot of this and now it's it's
like a free-for-all
it's like these pronoun things just take
exploding you got like a last time it
was like 100 20 30 different pronouns
and and whatnot
right and uh I think it was governor Ron
DeSantis Who removed some books from
school but the reasoning was it was uh
some of them were like pornography books
they had just straight up sexual like
pictures and and speeches for for young
kids and he removed them out of the
school and they're trying to act like
he's a Stalin or Hitler removing like
you know really serious books like oh
he's book burning and he he doesn't
believe in free speech and he's made it
clear he's like I don't think there
should be pornography in a kid's library
and I don't think they should be pushing
sexualization on them because you know
at the end of the day they want to
celebrate pride month for an entire
month which is like celebrating sodomy
and homosexuality and you know straight
couples make children and procreate the
human race that's just how it works you
know we wouldn't even exist without
people making babies so to celebrate a
whole month of that and then behind that
it's not just adults you know having
like sexual escapades they're using it
to Target young children and it it's
kind of like with abortion I you know I
have a certain stance on it but I
understand if someone is like when
they're trying to figure out when the
Life Starts and they don't understand
but you have certain left-wingers now
that will say up until birth you know
what I'm saying like it the the mother's
pregnant it's like coming out and there
was one uh Democrat who basically was
saying if the if the baby comes out like
that they can make a decision about it
like they're just talking about
slaughtering a half-born baby now yeah
this is murder I mean this is a a life a
human life it's really crazy and when
you see this happening
there was a clip of uh actually was um I
think it was a pastor I'm not uh
not um sure 100 but he was at the board
meeting I don't know if you saw that and
going back to what you were saying about
these books he started reading the book
it went
can we sir I'm sorry
was there something I said
was it something I said
in a school board meeting why should
children be able to check it out of the
school system
see we have perverts that are perverting
our kids
and you've all sit back smug in your
chairs and celebrate diversity equity
and inclusion but you don't want me to
read it so you can hear it
why does it bother you yes or no
you can't answer that question you wanna
know why
because politically speaking you can't
say that it's wrong right he was cut off
he was going into the book and then
somewhere along the lines that they were
like uh they were like hey hey slow down
there did you see that and then he said
hey you expect children to watch to look
at this to see this but you can't even
hear what I'm saying without even seeing
it did you see that I did yeah yeah
isn't that crazy it's crazy what's that
that book was in a library for children
and they're sure and they're showing
Zach is pornography you're seeing you're
seeing pictures of of adults coming
together and
doing uh what goes on in private uh in
your bedroom
I don't know if you saw Jen saki she was
the old press secretary for Joe Biden
but she came out recently and and
they're starting to figure out that a
lot of Muslims in America do not like
this similar to Christians and and she
basically was trying to say that the
reason Muslims don't like this stuff is
because white people are are tricking
them and I'm laughing because I'm like
you know when it comes to Islam and how
countries that are truly Islamic are
trying to be truly Islamic are are
dealing has nothing to do with white
people it's it's their belief also so I
think they're in for a rude awakening
they they tie everything back to white
people like as if and it's so demeaning
as if there's no other culture or race
or religion that that can think for
themselves right that everything has to
come back they think they're being nice
when they say stuff like that but it
really just shows that they don't think
other people have a mindset or or a
culture of their own so they're starting
to realize that Muslims do not overall
like like that yeah we have a clear
boundaries in Islam which is halal or
Haram I don't know if you heard the
terms Haram have you heard that term
yeah it means
don't do it don't do it it's prohibited
right something harmful for you so
what's Haram and what's uh Halal
permissible is is pretty straightforward
so this is the this is the thing that is
clearly defined it's laid out and
there's no confusion there's nobody
tricking us on that
I had a a Muslim driver that had to
drive me like three hours in Florida I
had to rush to get to like a different
part of it from off a cruise and I took
a very expensive Uber but I was like all
right three four hours I got to make
sure this guy's a cool guy because he's
driving me for three hours he was a
Muslim guy super cool guy but we're
talking and I and he starts talking
about what's going on with all the
rainbow stuff and I go I go that's Haram
and he go he looks back he goes how you
know about her um and then he loved me
because I said I said it was her Ramen
you know from then on it was a great a
great chat so he you know he gave me his
number and everything but he was so
impressed that I knew around I just did
a response to there's uh Patrick and
David and another Christian um I don't
know if he's a pastor Chris
um
you can help me out I forgot his name
but they were talking about putting
aside Patrick Ben David I think he was
in going in the right direction I don't
know your thoughts and I did a a I was
commending him for this about putting
aside any kind of theological difference
whatever the case to go ahead and unite
to be a force to be reckoned with to
come up against what's happening to our
children you see this uh in Canada
there's a big push now leave our kids
alone what what do you think about this
yeah I think that is gonna happen and I
think it I think it's a great idea and
you know I understand that there are
religious differences and you know
people have a right to their own
thoughts and their own culture but I do
think the propaganda in America is what
drove like inorganically I think
organically some people will drive
themselves apart but inorganically
through the war in Iraq and the war in
Afghanistan the anti-islam propaganda
was so strong in America that it drove
Christians and Muslims like so far away
for decades and everybody doesn't have
to be exactly the same I'm not saying
one world whatever but it's it really
was inorganic and now that that is
healing and people are seeing through
the propaganda they're starting to
realize that Christians are starting to
realize especially conservative
Christians that Islam are a lot of
people Envy the fact that certain
countries still hold those values dear
and this country doesn't because uh
Christians have been so weakened that
they think that it's only Saudi Arabia
it's only this and the reality is a lot
of these laws between uh husband and
wife like you can't stay at a hotel that
used to be in Catholic countries also
it's just it isn't anymore so yeah I
agree completely that people should
stand together on this stand firm in
their values and I think it's a natural
occurrence where the media and the
powers that be I think that they know
who the threats are against a One World
Government against this liberalization
of the world and they know that the two
their two biggest opponents are going to
be Islam you know the Middle East and uh
I would say Western Christian countries
that hold firm in their values so I
don't think it was a mistake that they
drove people so far apart I think it was
coerced because they they have to turn
the two strong factions that will fight
the propaganda against each other in
order to conquer how can you it's really
ironic I mean you have so many different
rules and regulations in place and you
have to to what is it to enlist in the
Army you got to be what it 18 or 21
to go to a tattoo parlor and get a
tattoo can you walk in at 11 years old
and get a tattoo
I think you need a parent you need a
parent right even to go and get your
passport you need uh here in Chicago you
need two parents to come in with you so
you need your parents along and then you
can go on with R-rated movies explicit
content all of this stuff there's rules
and regulations but why is it now when
it comes to taking off a fully a
functioning body part just like if you
were to go into to see a doctor and you
said hey man just I want to take this
arm off and take my eye out because I
feel like I'm a kid comes and says I
feel like I want to be a pirate you know
what I mean I feel I'm a pirate you know
so I'm going to put a patch on here so
you got to take my eye out and you want
to cut off my my arm here I want to put
a hook
what would the Doctor Who said you know
get the hell out of here no but he would
probably uh you know he would definitely
not he would definitely entertain this
but over here we're uh entertaining the
fact now that children here and pushing
it with the puberty blockers and you
know giving them time now to think about
this and then for helping to facilitate
them to go ahead and change uh their
genders so somebody sent me this clip of
people at a pride March shouting out uh
we're here we're queer and we're coming
for your children
of course when they were called out on
this they just said hey it's a joke it's
mockery you know kind of like the Gay
Men's Choir in San Francisco who said
the exact same thing so I get it you
guys like jokes I've got one for you
once upon a time there was a bunch of
people that threatened to mess with
other people's children and then when
they tried to make good on the attempt
they were brutally mauled beyond
recognition by a father who identified
as a grizzly bear see it's funny because
it would be true
right so for them to have a community
into the future they do need your
children
that's how they think for there to be a
homosexual Community 100 years from now
they need straight people's kids
because only straight people have
children
so they're very they're telling the
truth that's the first thing they mean
what they say and I think from a
religious perspective a lot of people
think that these rules like oh that
that's too crazy and they don't want you
to be free but there's a reason that God
wants people to be disciplined because
when you lean into the Haram it's like a
slippery slope you don't know saying it
starts with this so you see that with
the left if they were to say even when
they just got made gay people get
married if it would have stayed at that
most of the public probably would have
never even noticed because they're too
busy working Etc but then it's like well
now we're going to do it to a 17 year
old and it's like now we're going to do
it to a 14 year old now we're going to
do it to 10 year old now we're going to
do it to two-year-old now we're going to
abort a baby at seven months now nine
months now halfway through birth and
these people can't stop they're so
addicted to the Haram lifestyle that
they just go further further and further
into it and it's just crazy and what you
were saying with the identification it's
the same thing with voting uh I don't
care I know there's a political debate
going on but when you say hey should we
have an ID to vote because I need to go
on a cruise on a plane everything I do
to get a apartment anything and they say
oh no it's racist to have that and
people get so caught in the left and the
right and the emotion of it that they
don't think properly and it's like I'm
not asking people to be this way or this
way or or pledge allegiance to some
looser political party use your common
sense use the common sense that God gave
you should like you said if you can't
get a tattoo when you're 13 years old
should you be able to chop off your
genitals at seven you know what I'm
saying have a mother try to change your
gender at three years old it's nothing
to do with politics it's basic human
nature and people are so clouded that
they can't think straight
yeah and I think if you take out if you
take a higher power out of the equation
you take your creator out of the
equation and now and you're not living
for something greater and for a greater
purpose you're going to end up like we
were talking about you're talking about
jumping into you know debauchery you're
gonna don't jump into
experimenting and there's no guideline
everything's subjective so there's no
clear guidelines and then just make
things up as you go along so why why not
now right it's like right what what are
the who's setting the perimeters
and I think that in America a country
that really values Liberty Liberty from
government I think even conservatives
are falling into this trap where I call
it Freedom versus discipline freedom
from government like concentration camps
is good you don't want to be in there
you don't want them to take over but
discipline is what makes a man great not
Freedom it's discipline you know a
disciplined fighter there's a reason he
has eight pack abs if he he has the
freedom to eat Cheetos every day but the
reason that he's great is because of his
discipline so I think even a lot of
conservatives in America they lean so
hard into like freedom freedom freedom
and yes from government tyranny but
that's the reason the West I believe is
failing is because they don't have
discipline and they're too addicted to
just saying the word Freedom technically
Freedom means you could change your
gender of your three-year-old like that
you're free you know that's so you got
to be real careful with what the
parameters of society are and I know you
think about that yeah absolutely I don't
know it's a family from the show I'm
going to kind of describe this uh as
sensitively as possible but but we have
to educate our children we have to
educate ourselves because they're
educating them to the lifestyle that
they we God don't doesn't want them to
be indulging in and now with this whole
transition thing and the pronouns and
whatnot you had a person a man who was
um I don't know if you call a trade what
is it the trans and he was in I don't
know if you saw that clip he was in the
bathroom a woman's bathroom so he's
dressed as a woman he's in a woman's
bathroom and he's got his phone out but
then the the the private part of the his
obviously he's addressed as a woman but
he's got the male genitalia and it's a
and it's and it's uh it's a it's how
would you it's uh he's got a
how can I uh you know what I'm saying
have you seen the clip no yeah Joe Rogan
was talking about this so okay so he's a
man dressed as a woman he's in a woman's
bathroom and now someone's recording
recording that he's pretty much has a
erection
oh his
woman's bathroom right so he's uh
this is the kind of things that are
happening what do you what do you think
about this
yeah I mean I guess when you don't have
any guidelines for society and anything
goes stuff like that starts happening
they had that at Wii Spa in the Los Los
Angeles where they had a you know
biologically born man in the woman
section with with the junk hanging out
and women were complaining and they said
there's nothing we could do about it
they they use this sort of stuff as a
shield and they're they're very crafty
with it like if you disagree with them
you're a racist or a sexist or a bigot
or you must hate them and you must hate
people so it's a very crafty way of just
pushing the envelope further further
further further further and the second
you try to stop it then they say that
you're being hateful and you know the
the conservatives in America lose
because they they move what I call the
Overton window which is like the where
it's all happening it all moves so far
left that now if you look at the
Republican Party they're actually
further left on this topic than Obama
was when Obama got into office he said
that you know man and a woman is a
marriage before he leaves legalized it
because back in that day which was only
20 years ago you couldn't win an
election in America if you believed in
gay marriage even California voted
against it 20 less than 20 years ago so
now that's how they work the media and
the culture move so far left that then
the opposition to that is still further
along the line than it was that's why I
think religion is important and people
having strict values because I'm not
surprised this stuff's happening and you
know that I think the Republican party
doesn't have an answer for it they just
really just turned into the Democrats of
like 15 years ago how much do you think
that the freedom of speech is getting
eroded at and also the freedom of
religion now to go and practice your
religion and your religion obviously is
against these things and then also to
speak to use to use constructively
intelligently this what you have in the
Constitution this freedom of speech how
much you think this is being chipped
away at
uh definitely a lot like you were saying
during the lockdown we were experiencing
the craziest thing we've probably ever
seen which is like you're stuck in your
house you can't go anywhere you can't
run your business and then just voicing
opposition to that which is normal they
used private companies to to shut it
down but now we're finding out that the
government was talking to these
companies you know they're reaching out
saying this is illegal or don't you know
don't let them do this so I think it's
definitely happening I do think that
there is some more competition on the
horizon but say even Rumble you know if
they're on the Apple store they're
beholden to Apple so there's one
platform that never bent the knee their
name is Gab you know gab.com and they
call them anti-semitic because basically
there's this rule that if you want to
stay on the App Store you have to play
along to a certain speech regulation
guideline and gab.com never did it so
they got kicked off the whole App Store
now the only way to find them is on a
browser but anyone including Rumble
including you know these Free Speech
Advocates there's a certain game that
you have to play to stay on the App
Store and if you're not on Apple App
Store it's hard to you can't really
compete with social media so yeah
there's a lot of little tricks they have
I think to control the Paradigm of what
you can and can't say so far are we
doing okay
with what we can't what we could what we
can and can't say oh no yeah you're good
for sure I mean I I think
I've been fine over the last couple
years I'm always pretty thoughtful about
what I say as long as you're just not
like aggressively freaking out over like
crazy topics to me they do censor some
stuff but a lot of people are a little
sloppy with it you know as long as
you're not super sloppy okay uh let's
get into a couple more things I want to
talk about this lab grown meat can you
talk about that fill us in on what's
going on with the lab girl meet
yes I guess they found a way to grow
meat in a lab you know I don't
understand the scientific process but
it's not real you know it's not like a
cow giving birth to a cow and you eat it
it's fake it's obviously fake huh
well they claim it's real meat but it's
the claim it's real they're claiming
it's real
well I yeah I wouldn't consider it real
but and also this they'll claim it's
safe and you know it's it's safe and
effective and it's it's going to save
the world from climate change or
whatever the thing is but you know
there's a certain Beauty to Nature
there's a certain Beauty to like a bunch
of bees creating a a honeycomb and you
look at it and it looks so beautiful
it's like the perfect shape right and
then the Honey's got all these nutrients
and now you're just taking a cow and
somehow growing its meat in a lab and
it's very it's very weird and
I I don't want any part of it personally
but to each their own yeah this is um
again something going off from the the
natural way and when you go away from
the natural way the way that God
Almighty has put things in order then
you have disorder and I don't I don't
see um and always it's always
masqueraded in something positive is
good but then uh you see just all of
these uh destructive things that happen
after that it becomes like a big big
business people benefiting over a
People's Health and not really taking
those things into consideration
and I won't say too much because I know
it's a topic like I I don't have
problems with this because I word it
properly but I think with climate change
they're going to do very similar stuff
that they did with kovid which is
basically like you can't question the
data right you know these this is like
they did this is the science don't
question it or else we'll kick you off I
think they're going to do that same sort
of thing and part of that equation is
they're saying that you know cows are
and farms are a problem and in certain
European countries they're starting to
shut down farmland and tell Farmers you
know you're causing climate but without
saying too much you look at the world
and say a country like Ireland or
Netherlands their impact on the world is
very small compared to America or China
so this idea that that's even gonna you
know make a dent in in the science is is
nuts but I guess that's their thought is
like we gotta start with us and then
everyone else will follow aren't these
the same people are saying follow the
science and now they can't determine
even if a man's a man a woman's a woman
right I mean it's it's definitely pretty
uh if you're paying attention it's
obvious that they they can't do basic
math or science yet they're the experts
have you heard I'm gonna teach you
another term shaytan
have you heard this term shaytan
shaytan is uh will be equivalent to this
is the master deceiver Iblis the devil
then you have underneath the shaytan you
have little
so this is the devil and the satanic
forces uh we would say working
okay yeah for sure Humanity right yeah
uh so let's uh finish off here with one
more thing that you also you you
discussed uh you talked about Andrew
Tate uh getting framed
so being a news analyst and Reporting on
many of these things what was your
conclusion to the whole Andrew Tate
being locked up in Romania
whatever yeah
I don't think he's a human trafficker I
think he's probably done what would be
considered Haram you know I don't know
for sure but his whole like little no
definitely that's not that's that's no
Shadow of Doubt you know that webcam all
of that stuff that is definitely uh
those things uh are Haram yes from the
past yeah
and listening to them because I like
Andrew Ted I think he's super
interesting to listen to and I think
they're mad at him because he basically
awoken a lot of young men into not being
pathetic but listening to him and you
know his brother I like both of them
they have a lot of pride in their past
and I think that was kind of an error
just like it's one thing to everybody
makes mistakes and everyone does stuff
but like they're so proud of like
scamming men and lying to them and they
just always were talking about that on
podcasts but here's the thing it's not
human trafficking a lot of people
they're glorifying it I think for the
podcast realm but a lot of these only
fans women have guys that are doing the
messaging you know it's a full-blown
business so that's not actually that
unusual
um and as far as flying women and doing
stuff it was not human trafficking in my
opinion I don't think they were flying
women against their will I think a lot
of women wanted to do it they wanted to
hang out with them
um it's just the way they talked about
it they talked about it so often and so
recklessly that they're using anything
that they can get against them and
trying to to frame them on it so I don't
think they're guilty of human
trafficking uh although I I just I think
it was just a bad move of them being
like you know lie to these women and and
bang them and make them love you then
you do them into the webcam it's just
kind of dumb to just say that publicly
so many times but I in in a court I mean
saying something dumb doesn't mean you
you trafficked like women for for that
reason so I do think that if they had
never gotten famous and and woken up a
lot of young men I don't know that they
would be charged like this personally I
think it's a
I hope that they get a fair court for
sure
yeah that was uh interesting that
through because you have a lot of people
who will do things uh for for likes for
shares for you know in the social media
realm just to be as outlandish as
possible and you have people who are
saying and doing far worse things I mean
equally in in Islam uh these things are
obviously Haram right but we do believe
that people can change for the better we
we want people to change for the better
that's how the world becomes a better
place when people leave off things like
that only fans and pornography and all
of these the the life of debauchery this
is something that really you know Islam
is about worshiping one God and being
morally upright very simple found the
foundation that you live your life on
and you're conscious of your creator at
all time you make a mistake you turn
back you ask for forgiveness and that's
how we should be as a society when
somebody's you know trying to change for
the better not to push them back and
hold them to their past for the rest of
their life if they say I'm done with
that why are you going to keep bringing
it up over and over and trying to uh not
help someone to grow so
that's the ironic thing
yeah and if you read the court case like
this is the problem too like a lot of
people who hate Andrew Tate they'll just
see the headline
I'm obviously a Muslim I'm Islamic what
most people don't understand about a lot
of the Islamic world is that a lot of
these things are outlawed right I even
see both sides of politics they're
saying why is Tucker Carlson
interviewing a human trafficker
this is America's most famous Admiral
you know it's it's so such an important
issue for our youth and adults as you
said some of these laws are actually
extending into adulthood you know we
often say that gender affirm and Care is
Health Care gender affirming care is
mental health care and gender affirming
care is literally Suicide Prevention
care would that be your view as well I
100 percent agree
it's so it's genuinely I want to
actually genuinely give my heartfelt
condolences to any young person who
falls for this crap because you're going
to be so miserable for the rest of your
life if you chop off your genitals take
a whole bunch of chemicals as a teenager
you are going to be miserable for the
rest of your life yes you're never going
to be the person you want to be you're
never going to be accepted as that
person you're never going to feel happy
inside if you fall for this I genuinely
feel sorry for you even right winger
said that and I'm I'm like you guys are
so pathetic like he can't interview
people now you're trying to Blacklist an
interview Tucker can interview whoever
he wants and even if Tate was guilty of
that I don't think he is he could still
be interviewed that's what the
journalism is for but you read the court
case and the headline versus the you
know the gist of it just isn't adding up
like a lot of these these accusations
are so flimsy
um I think in a fair court that the Tate
brothers will be innocent so hopefully
they get that I don't know how Romania
works but yeah I mean
it's that's it's rough going through all
this yeah how do you see that playing
out now so they got uh they were in the
Romanian dungeon for for several months
there was it like three months something
like that and now they're on house
arrest and then right at the end before
the time expired they threw some charges
on them I think it was something with um
uh something with the um getting girls
to do The Tick Tock videos and taking
their money something like that and I
don't know what else uh I don't know if
you remember
so I haven't seen the new charges I
remember the original ones that got them
locked up but I haven't been following
uh it seems like they're throwing the
kitchen sink at them yeah I hope they
have good lawyers and I I can't imagine
what the courts are like in Romania
hopefully they're fair but
um
you know I I hope that they get off and
uh yeah I don't
I'm not buying the the whole story
although I think that
some of the stuff they were saying is
definitely not good but I don't I don't
think it's it's not trafficking you know
saying if anything it's like put there's
women who have played man and you know
dated them for their money and stuff and
went on a bunch of trips and then broke
up with them is that evil yes is it
illegal you know what I'm saying to lie
to somebody and and deceive them I don't
I don't think it's uh I don't think
that's trafficking so we'll see like
Tick Tock videos that's not it's not
human trafficking and you had some of
these women I mean this is the thing
that obviously any kind of um
any
if you have it kind of takes away from
people who are really being abused and
really being targeted and defenseless uh
human beings women be it rather men or
women but in this case women but it kind
of takes away because it seems like the
some of these uh women from who are
alleged victims you have one group
saying we're not victims and they're
saying you guys can't pretty much think
for yourself so we're gonna we're gonna
use you here on our side the
prosecutor's side then you have the
others who've also made these
allegations I believe against other men
and then you also you had the London
case not too long ago you have men being
accused of certain things and then you
had um then what happens is they get
their whole lives ruined pretty much you
know they get uh pretty this sticks with
them their whole life but then later
they get exonerated they're free but the
stigma still stays with them it's
already they're destroyed for life
right yeah without playing the victim I
think men always get the worst end of of
court cases especially in marriage Etc
you know the man is always uh being
treated a little rougher and with them I
mean we just experienced the biggest
like human trafficking scandal with the
Epstein just Lane Maxwell thing in
America and none of the media seems
really that concerned about that none of
the presidential candidates are running
on that to suggest that Andrew Tate and
and Tristan Tate is the big story is
clearly not you know they're just super
super famous I think Andrew became like
the most famous person in the world and
uh you know when you get that big
people come out of the Woodworks and
it's just like getting a lot of money
then all of a sudden people from your
past start suing you and all of a sudden
they have a problem I don't I don't
think a lot of this stuff would have
came to light if Andrew never got so big
and famous and to be fair obviously this
is maybe a bigger charge than some
others are charged with but that happens
very often whenever anyone makes a lot
of money publicly everybody every weasel
from the past starts coming out saying
oh I want a piece of that pie
yeah so um
that was uh pretty much uh brought us up
to speed on some of the things that are
going on some of the things that you've
covered if people want to go ahead and
look into some more of uh the news get
some because the they're fed up with all
the lies from the mainstream media and
and you take how do you do it what's
your pers what's your procedure how do
you encourage people to do the critical
thinking you know to practice these
critical thinking skills to kind of do
what you do what kind of formula would
you go
I would say just try to use common sense
because what I'm starting to see now and
maybe it's just my atmosphere is a lot
of people became politically active
right they saw what was going on and
they became politically active but when
it comes to the two-party system
although I do believe one is slightly
better than the other and living in
reality a little more there's a lot of
traps and tricks in the two-party
American system so what I don't want
people to do is like they get so excited
and then they become what they hate and
then they become biased and then they
become brainwashed by the Republican
party instead of the democratic party
and they don't critically think then too
so I think people have to be really
open-minded because there is a lot of
like you know influencer traps where if
you get in a new Echo chamber they start
feeding you just like one-sided stuff so
for me
um it's been tough this last year or two
because a lot of my peers that I thought
were very honest and stuff I realized
they're the fake version of the other
side so if you pay attention just always
try to you know not be too emotional
optional over politicians they're like
car salesmen you know they're not your
religious leader they're not your family
member they're a politician so just just
have critical thinking skills really
think about it and don't be afraid to
challenge what you hear from any news
station because I uh I think a lot of
new age people that kind of took over
the mainstream media in my view not to
be pessimistic or anything but they're
they're just as fake as the old guard
and now a lot of people are falling for
that so
um you know just don't don't be overly
like uh culty about any politician or
political thing and and then just just
check out the story see what you think
sometimes sometimes I feel like people
who get so immersed in the politics
you're almost better not to right it's
not good to be ignorant you don't want
to be lied to but I think there's a lot
of traps out there so you know I try to
do my best to educate people and bring
the truth there but
it's a crazy world of social media I'm
sure you know it's like you can get
caught in an algorithm really quick and
sometimes it's just like a hamster wheel
Loop so I try to even avoid that myself
because I get trapped in it sometimes
too just looking at certain issues yeah
anomaly thank you thank you for being
with us yeah thanks for having me always
a pleasure and uh maybe I'll have you on
the show one time we could weigh in on
some some topics that that you're good
at sounds good thank you brother take
care appreciate you all right peace
our brother in Islam Eddie from the dean
show is creating the dean Center which
is a Masjid and a dawa Center which is
going to help non-muslims learn about
Islam inshallah and the most beautiful
thing about this is that we can all be a
part of this we can all take part in
earning rewards from this simply by
donating whatever we can to make this a
reality which is beautiful let's do that
all right let's click this link let's
donate what we can and let's make this a
reality Insha'Allah
[Music]
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you